and now it's time for bumming reviews
with Chester a bum
tonight's review Branca oh my god this
is your greatest movie I've ever seen in
my life reach for it the spoilers
there's this lizard called brain goo gee
are you wait go over here excuse me one
moment
yes don't all right if there's anyone
who should be reviewing this movie it's
me why you may ask
there are two reasons number one I don't
want it told by some eccentric nutballs
who stoned off his ass what number two
this movie should be reviewed by me
because well I'm in it you heard me
correctly I'm in it and they didn't even
give me credit well maybe that's because
I'm not exactly in it it's a look-alike
a phony one of the many impersonators
rlep you just like that idiot with the
big forehead I'm lying
perhaps I should explain in better
detail alright so you have this lizard
he talks for some God knows why reason
and of course my initial thought is I'm
in the middle of a goddamn hotel zoo and
I saw her BAM I mean it's a lizard he's
in a cage there you go you see he is a
pet lizard in a car he falls out of the
car the cage breaks and who does he run
into me that's right I'm sitting here
driving the car with my Wolfman attorney
in the neck where'd he go anyway and
suddenly this lizard fart in front of
the windshield and I simply look at the
lizard and say I knew it that's it
that's my big cameo what a fricking
ripoff clearly I should have been the
star of this movie
it has talking animals and images that
make no sense that's my everyday life
instead we follow this lizard it was a
voice similar to mine but not as sexy as
he comes across some town in the Wild
West that's right lizards are Cowboys
now there's other animals there too like
squirrels rabbits and squirrels but this
begs the question if a lizard was just
some pet animal the kids cage then he'll
know how can they talk and build
civilizations I'll tell you how the
writer take some acid and it is kiss my
ass I do flaky movie if I'm movie like
this is gonna be this trippy you might
as well give us the drugs to fully enjoy
it there you get some drugs
hey sir yeah we went from an artsy drug
house film to a Western again how many
movies have done that already one too
many so it turns out this Western talent
is in great need of water in fact water
is pretty much their currency it's how
they buy things
right now we're ripping off - which
isn't a bad idea considering how nobody
saw it but it turns out somebody steals
the water and they call in Rango to
solve the case
why because I made him Sheriff
apparently he fooled everybody into
thinking he's a fearsome outlaw where
really he isn't just like hundreds
Thompson fooled everybody entertaining
Emerald Duke is a fictional character
right so he gets everybody together to
go and find the water meanwhile there's
this very algae bear that's playing
about how he's going to die
hiiii we're building up to all that down
so they come across a bunch of moles
that apparently stole the water Oh Ranko
steals the water away from the moles so
the moles call upon their most fearsome
weapon that's holy geez they're great
surfers but then they figure out that
the moles didn't steal the water it was
done by the evil there who everybody
could tell is gonna be an evil bear if
there's anything I've learned in all my
years it's never trust a turtle good
advice and just when Rango is about to
reveal the mayor's plan a giant snake
comes in reveals that the sheriff is not
a sheriff he's a lizard
so Ringo walks through his path of
despair as the rest of the characters
say so long we look forward to your
obvious ethical turnaround in ten
minutes
but then Ringo comes across Clint
Eastwood I'm totally serious comes
across Clint Eastwood like I said where
are the drugs and so Clint Eastwood
tells him no man can escape his own
story but again hire a different voice
actor to replace his part
Rango says you're right so he goes back
to the town and gets everybody to help
him they even get a bunch of the best
together make the snake think they're a
hawk and the snake looks up and says we
can't stop here this is hot country but
then he finds out that the hawk was
nothing but a bunch of bats and the
snake says we can stop here this is not
pork country and since we're a bunch of
boom bang boom Rango gets a water-pipe
to the town then fills it with water
hopefully drumming those little critters
tinta and so gringo lives happily ever
after and of course I say to myself
bullshit you promised me he was gonna
die isn't our car to squash him into
roadkill
but then the Owls tell us hey we rip you
off big-time force it when you tell me
that was it is gonna die I expected
moszer tonight companies would have shot
him or something no he's probably like I
had to make another movie that shows
life's a bitch and then you die
so bottom line Rango was a very
movie the headed over complicated
storyline that could have been a lot
simpler dad mentioned the director of
Pirates of Caribbean did this this was
rope you father of fuzzy journalism
saying I have a cup I still have a cup
never trust a turtle